put that one in the Hall of Fame but just
a magnificent effort to get that left leg
Pat over there driving to the outside help from
McMichael Gibbon go right to the crease stopped
two of them by Gibson the last one on McMichael
preventing that tuck in and John Gibson just
kind of hung in there with that left leg pad
that that is an enormous save save that how
did he sa that I had forane from the breaking
King fabry hit the go post are you serious Fab
thinks it's in picker got a piece of that with
his blocker or that Pucks in the net it went
off the blocker off the crossbar and off the far
goal post that's as close as it gets but it was
bickered and his blocker that saved that pocket
from going in the net making it a two nothing
game fetch neov brings it back in for AO and
a big save by Gibson back in front of Gibson
with a 10 Bell stop I think everybody in
the building thought it was one to nothing
but John Gibson said no John Gibson watch
him get across and get that left toe over
towards the post and he absolutely robs
Seth Jarvis Ste by Matthews loades what
what Skinner denying home flashing
leather and the champ of Stew goes
up at Rogers this is an outrageous save he
gets it up too and Skinner turns him aside
chance here londell puts it in front for lomberg
back to londell oh and Gibson stretched out and
got a piece of that buck little chaos and
boy what a great stop with the right toe
by John Gibson watch him drive off that left
skate and just extend the right leg to deny
Anton londell what a great stop coming into
today's action as the cats break in Stan's P
bled turned aside by the left pad of Gibson
this is a two two on0 Breakaway stenland to
EAD and Gibson but just a magnificent
effort to get that left leg Pat over
there prer a save we oh what a save by
lren on prer second shot unbelievable
and that's the catching myth we've always
raved about here's the low one here's the
top one what a stop highlight
re quality by Charlie lingren
save his mat out of the net oh mercy
R what a save put that one in the Hall
of Fame father Finn with the leather on one
of the all-time greats two nothing Carolina
rason drives the lane gets the pass Bram sto
by S A two-on-one and a saucer pass with the
backand and you can see sliding cross almost
had a chance going five hole comfor drops
to break a dangerous shooting loose pule
with a stop Samson off across and he robed
what looked like a sure Detroit goal watch
this to Brink it with the shot the rebound
there conord oh man what a great save by
Samson off diving across and making the
save Anthony mantha off the skate of McMichael
fan on and now a turnover McMichael stopped
by DOR a couple of times in tight oh two
unbelievable stops here by Joey dord the
first time I watch the second time right there
oh oh my goodness you talk about save of the
night and look at the reaction from Chris
dger that's going to be on the Highlight
tonight throughout the National Hockey League
Stone the petrangelo his drive hit low R barers
and he had it stopped in front and San made
the save what a chance for barers chef and
there there's the right pad of San stretched
out to make the stop oh great save by swayan
flashed up that right pad to Rob barbashev
and then Swinging with a tremendous stop by
barbashev Anderson L It Center glove St by
soard to Rob through in thought they had the
tying gold soard with a fantastic save Randon is
going to slide it back door for Duran soar Rees
out and gets the glove on at the last second
for boquist David poock cuts into the middle
as petrangelo fell down and Thompson with a great
stop on poster knock he flashed out the glove to
Rob one of the game's best goal scorers a little
dangle to the inside goes to the back hand and a
great glove save by Logan Thompson well that save
for the first shot of the game and what a move by
David poer Pucket Center chance for Crosby di go
the save and then Crosby put the rebound through
the crease and out the the other side not an
orthodox save but whatever it takes that leaves
Crosby wide open Demco with the stop what a save
by Demco feed to Kyu Thomas mavic shoots it what
a save by Swan with his arm on mavic pav bhavit
gets a great opportunity here what a save there
by slaman alvich pass in front save oh another
great save just sturken on Jordan CYO what a
pass by pav bunic and then Jordan Kyra looking to
put that one in but eigor shurkin sprawling over
there split pad save fires have it back one more
push there's connecting with L connly moving up to
lot in the shut oh the save by Primo spectacular
woo unbelievable great action end to end what a
save by Kaden Primo coming across M walks it alone
stop up Dy by driger drier reads the play but Zan
had with speed on the back hand and nice blocker
Sav by Chris dger really good stop by dger from
Rasmus darene here's tuck side of the O across get
go with the glove best save of the game sliding to
his left as he robbed Casey middl cousins across
bit of no looker for middlest stat but guess who's
there with the left hand thater demo stretches all
the way across and holds that one out Sebastian AO
early Breakaway shot oh Tristan jari welcome
to the hockey game jari said get out of here
19 seconds all alone well stay in the obvious
here but not the way the Penguins wanted to
start